it was a bonding experience i can't say
we were very good but we gave it again
bridgeton season 2 brought platters full
of scones sets covered in real gold
gifts being left in trailers countless
props stolen from set and way less of
their signature steamy scenes this
scandal does continue though so let's
peek behind the curtain to see what
exactly was going on in the bridge
reverse while filming the second season
the fact that we have so much fun in
something like that hopefully that will
come through number one they didn't know
what hit them
mad
mad is one way to put it but ashley has
also said it was amazing and an
experience she's deeply grateful for
ashley's co-star and on-screen sister
felt similarly i mean it was absolutely
mental it was a a big um car scene so
everyone was there and these two got
thrown into the deep end their very
first time on set being one of the epic
family meal scenes luckily it all worked
out sort of the best scene to start with
because we got to meet everyone at once
there was loads of down time to chat and
get to know each other the cast from
season one was extremely supportive with
jonathan bailey insisting simone felt
safe as a newcomer on set meanwhile
their co-star katherine drizdale was
busy singing their praises
i think we were all a bit sort of like
star struck we'd be starstruck on this
set that's for sure number two if that
wig doesn't get under control it might
be off with her head with wigs that take
up the screen the production team made
sure the queen charlotte actress could
get the support she needed they actually
made me a neck brace considering she was
spending hours on end carrying all that
extra weight on top of her head she felt
it was important to consult with the
costume department to make sure she was
able to do her job while looking this
lavish i could just put my neck in and
just yeah
number three
we've got seem of another variety this
season
i think it's quality over quantity on
the second season we we
we're expressing sex and intimacy in a
more psychological kind of way while
there are far less of the famous steamy
bridgeton scenes the ones that are
included well according to ashley the
fireworks are even bigger when it does
all happen and it's very earned the
producers decided that for the rest of
the seasons they wanted to focus on
other forms of intimacy they were naked
in front of each other psychologically
before they were physically the shift
has made for a really positive
experience for the on-screen couple
i think it allowed us as actors to kind
of just dive into the character's
development filming with the female gays
in mind made for some pretty special
moments that's for sure
number four cross every t dot every eye
while there were less intimate scenes
they weren't any less intense so extra
contracts were signed the day of
outlining every detail of how much would
be revealed on camera as well as where
contact would happen and how doing all
they could to make sure every actor felt
safe and supported on set included in
this was a rule that indicated whenever
an intimate scene was taking place
between two people there had to be three
different objects acting as a barrier
between their bodies but there is i
remember one of them was a was it the
john lewis travel cushion and there was
a half inflated netball in the kit too
talk about being resourceful number five
anytime is snack time at least for colin
bridgerton and luke newton i'm a biscuit
fiend and so is colin i think we share
that
the actor really wanted to do justice to
the character and he listened to what
the fans wanted a lot of the fans of the
books love colin eating food so this
year i really tried any time colin
bridgeton could be eating newton would
check with production to see if the
plate of food in front of him could be
piled up to make sure his intense
snacking habits came across just one
scone could never do
anyone else want to move into the
bridgerton mansion the giant soundstage
the bridgerton team often films in
definitely does the trick and i often
get lost in there it's it's enormous the
modist is in fact a fully constructed
set based on a shop and bath a location
the team once had but lost part way
through filming the first season so they
built their own version it's a huge
sound stage there are like three stages
i think will's club
fully built and even painted with real
gold so that's real and of course
there's the tea shop this is based on
like two or three real streets in bath
featuring beautiful but not so tasty
baked goods they're generally
oh wow styrofoam oh and notice all the
portraits of the actors custom made
no big deal the woman who does like
these amazing paintings of all of us is
also lady with around hand number seven
it's time to play hide and seek how many
hiding places could there be on a set
well in her shop actress katherine
drisdale had plenty i can put my like my
phone in the little like silk rolls and
things like that she could store her
stuff and special fuel to help her get
through those long days or a little
snack under the counter in the shop
number eight the competition is getting
real
batter batter up the palm all scenes
were filled with action laughter and
some very competitive spirits no
surprise it was a favorite among the
cast members it's kind of wild though
some of them might have gotten a bit too
into the game pal now scenes i got to
spend a lot of time with the cast
outdoors playing this game and we were
really playing the game luke thompson
gave the props department a whole lot of
extra work
i broke six mallets during filming yeah
one after the oculus yeah it was very
embarrassing number nine a perfect
romance on screen but what you see isn't
always what you get
simone ashley and jonathan bailey loved
working together but they're animal
co-stars well let's just say they could
have worked on their timing you're doing
a beautiful scene very romantic and it's
going really well and then a horse just
takes a dump how about messy and muddy
romance moments
although falling in the mud to lose its
novel
the first time they filmed it it was
actually a bit too messy he got way too
into it by the end we were getting mud
all over our face yeah we had to
re-shoot because the hysteria number ten
who needs to breathe anyway i think
you'd love to wear a corset and then
you'd have one on for an hour and you go
maybe this is not as great
those corsets were rough and restricted
the actors wearing them in more ways
than one i couldn't really eat
though some newcomers didn't seem to
mind them too much
they're perfectly made for us so it many
ways it does feel like second skin the
boys of course had it much easier than
the women and they knew it but let's
hear them out for me it's the tie and
actually i feel very guilty complaining
about being uncomfortable in the costume
because i know the women of the show
have a very difficult time and both
luke's could have done without the
restrictively shaped suit jackets number
11 wardrobe one actor zero we are big
fans of jonathan bailey fencing but
filming the seeds were tough for the
actor who struggled with his tight pants
going in for my final lunch with
benedict my crotch ripped and it's all
on camera oh and there were a full four
cameras on him at the time
screaming this is just so embarrassing
in the middle of set was all he could do
nicola cochlin's country ball dress
really slowed her down this pink beaded
number that i weared a country ball and
it was so stunning but it weighed a ton
and it got her in a bit of trouble with
production they were like can you run
quicker and i was like no i physically
can't number 12. sometimes going method
is very very cute we were like a little
married couple simone ashley and
jonathan bailey treated each other very
well as co-stars johnny and i would
leave little presents inside each
other's trailers so every month he would
leave a bouquet of flowers in my trailer
and then i would leave his favorite
snacks in his trailer but ashley wasn't
the only one he was leaving presents for
on set he loves muesli and i remember
walking in and there was a little bag of
music that it was his favorite some of
my accounts never change number 13. when
the families are together it's always a
party they're always my favorite when
the family are together many of the
actors reveled in getting to spend so
much time looking so fabulous with so
many people they love but it did make
for a bit of a marathon we do end up
being exhausted by about 11 30 am
because we've been laughing so much
together because we get really giddy
when we're all in the room together
number 14. which actors wound up on the
naughty list i was very good student and
i didn't take anything not everyone was
ashley though i nicked some fake
wisteria because most of the flowers are
fake yeah oh but that wasn't all and i
took one of the little dance cards to
the cards you wear on your wrist actress
bessie carter had the same idea i can't
tell you exactly what but i stole a
dance card from one of the balls of all
the actors this sneakiness is most like
nicholas character and she wasn't
ashamed after all lady whistle down
wouldn't be but the mystery i didn't ask
i just was like yoink in the bag number
fifteen there were details hidden on
screen and behind the scenes nicola
cochlin was pretty out of the loop as to
what was happening in the second season
because the creators were being so quiet
about the plot lines and stories to come
the actress was quick to investigate
trying to piece together every detail
she could once a lady whistle down
always a lady whistle down
just when we think we can't love this
show anymore we're ready to binge it all
over again what part of the making of
the show did you find most surprising